chemical tank trailers are built to
ensure that a potentially harmful cargo
arrives safely their design is tightly
regulated because safety is in
everyone's best interests they build the
chemical tank from scratch they start
with a big sheet of heavy duty stainless
steel pressurized rollers curl it into a
cylinder that will become half of the
tanks inner vessel using a crane they
transfer the 20-foot long rounded
section to a welding station here an
operator controls a semi-automatic
welder with a joystick the welder joins
the two sides of the sheet to complete
the cylinder they bring two cylinders
together to form a 40-foot long inner
vessel this scene is near the midpoint
it will be subject to significant
bending stress and transport it's
critical that this weld is perfect the
team caps the end with metal disks known
as heads they tack weld the heads to the
vessel first and assure that the fit is
exact then a semi-automatic welder does
a permanent well
next they weld three long half pipes
along the bottom the three pipe serve as
a heating panel keeping the chemical
cargo in a liquid state this is
important because when some chemicals
solidify their purity is compromised the
team slides the first of many metal
rings on to the tank and clamps each
ring to the shell a worker does the
initial tack welds then a semi-automatic
welder makes the full welds after
attaching a steel framework to the
bottom
a crane transfers the inner vessel to
the trailer a worker tucks insulation
between the vessel and the trailer he
secures the tank to the trailer with
intermittent welds known as stitch welds
another member of the team wraps strips
of rigid foam around the steel vessel he
spaces the foam evenly apart and pulls
them tightly against the vessel with
metal strapping this creates
compartments for fiberglass insulation
he tucks the insulation into the spaces
blanketing the vessels so the chemical
freight will stay warm and fluid the
team now builds the outer shell they
pull stainless steel sheets around the
inner vessel using thick nylon ties
a worker welds the sheets in place
completing the outer shell once a
manhole has been installed at the top
the crew builds a metal platform around
it this platform allows a person to
access the manhole without slipping or
denting the outer shell of the tank a
worker attaches a ladder to the tank it
will be used for accessing the manhole
another member of the team connects led
tailights
and inserts them in light boxes at the
back of the trailer it takes about five
days to build a chemical tank trailer
they last for 30 years or more so this
trailer should be good for the long haul